hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bad dream Hospital the
third part in the six part series of bad
dream games and it's proving to be very
very interesting to me at least I hope
you guys are enjoying it as much as I am
but either way turn down your lights
again turn up your volume and get ready
to explore the adventure of Madden oh no
it's a teddy bear body oh no it's the
headless teddy bear why does it have an
IV I oh god damnit I really need to be
careful again about where I put my
fingers
okay so colors oh I need the color so
the background supposed to be blue the
sun's supposed to be Yeller red apple
green leaves and brown tree trunk that
seems pretty simple to me is that
supposed to be a guide for something I'm
supposed to remember down the road
hey cool hallway I don't like that why
is there a patch on the ground oh good
oh it's like Freddy's no god damn it I
need to stop knocking stuff over hi
Sammy was a knife go away stop peeping
on me
yeah frickin weirdo oh god damnit I'm so
ugly I broke the mirror dammit Oh God
and I got the color brown I got the
color brown hi okay bye okay okay what
did I die the color brown I couldn't do
anything I tried to click on the door
god damn it I've lost all my brown ok
old liquids
right ok then this is meat meat in there
oh I love me how's it going for a
patient how are you are you enjoying
your meat finger soup special that's
that's funny
HAP it's the funny knock that over
because I think you're so weird
go back in oh oh ok that's locked
all right how's it going how are you
doing today you feel good
I'll just take all your stuff don't mind
me all right have a nice life okay Oh
what is this like some impossible
geometry [ __ ] going on here
BAM oh I can't knife you damn it okay
wait that wasn't even pumping out water
before why was it doing it now all right
whatever are you gonna ask questions hmm
so I got a knife a dirty plate and
nothing else so am I supposed to do
something about all oh oh oh ah there we
go I need to find a fork so do you have
a fork or do you know where I could find
a fork dude bro dude man anybody Fork I
need a fork okay so there's got to be a
fork around here somewhere so I need a
fork where's a goddamn fork is so hard
to find a goddamn fork you have a fork
bro you want to pass me a fork through
your little peeping hole okay fine
whatever oh okay I got laxatives okay so
I don't get ah there we go
Oh am I about to get my brown again bye
hello oh you're gone I wonder where you
went
oh all right then all right okay thanks
and now I got my brown again why oh why
[Laughter]
all right then Wow okay that's not from
the laxatives what how I don't know oh
so now it's a passable area okay I see
what's going on here
sorry I was just trying to look at it
and I broke it again cuz I'm so
horrifically ugly all right
don't close your eyes or we'll meet
again oh no I closed that eye
why did I why do I keep exploding these
eyes I don't know what that is
brave patient award good I got a sticker
oh I keep breaking everything I touch
such a menace to society well I'm glad
that so horrifying here clear as day in
normal out here horrifying
all right oh I should go in there this
life is not real don't worry I'll wake
you too
it's like it's fake I'll give you life
open your eyes death here equals birth
their death here is birth there so I
need to die here oh I like your madness
Thanks you like my turd and blood
drawing it's a great great use of art
here I like it a lot thank you for
appreciating it ok so ok so that's the
end of the hallway that I can't go in
now alright so I got red there we go so
I got that needle and I got more red
coloring just in case I needed it again
so I need to take this needle and put it
somewhere also if I could find a fork
that'd be great
I don't know if I'm gonna find that do
you need a needle congratulations you
got a brave patient Award for peeping in
on everybody and also screaming really
loud
well good now someone can take a shower
I guess so that's cool in privacy ok
Oh alrighty then okay so that's full of
poison but once again why would that
need to be a thing why do I need oh good
a rag can I make it a poison rag okay so
I need to take this rag and I need to do
something with it
horrible horrible okay back at the
horrible horrible horrible oh no I got a
green rag gray oh wait no I thought oh I
thought I was gonna be right on that one
hmm I guess I oh well why did I do that
hi hey nurse how you doing pretty lady
you looking so good with you in here
that makes you look like grudge and or
the ring oh alright
oh good more okay there's more now this
is a fun room this is a fun room I like
this room a lot I like it so much time I
leave and never come back
oh it's an even better one people to
save crazy man fat man doctor nurse you
I'm not gonna save the nurse am i I
really wish I could save the nurse okay
I got thread he won't bother you again
the doctor got a stethoscope okay Oh
people saved
killing oh you're killing them it's not
I need to save them you're just killing
them okay there's more red if I wanted
it so badly
hi nurse yeah well I got a nickel happy
about that so I guess I can go get
myself a fresh refreshing liquid this
isn't the liquid I wanted just saying
great Oh nurse you're still here
congratulations for being alive
this place is terrible that place oh go
to gift for me I should open that again
I just got punched in the face why do I
keep opening those things it's a
terrible decision alright whatever so I
got to you want to lady anybody wants to
head one tooth
maybe my bear wants the tooth I don't
know
go on tooth on tools maybe oops maybe
baby
not good not good no one wants a tooth
there okay so you want do it em I want
don't go see don't say I don't know I'm
not sure exactly what I'm supposed to do
now oh I got the poison in the urine
sample container good hey nurse
you want some poison nurse I know what
I'm doing references I don't like this
place it's not good okay so what do I do
with the poison Oh splash Oh God a
thermometer why was that inside him
there's various answers to that question
but I don't want any of them oh I have a
fever
where'd you go why'd you go away what
does that mean oh hey what is that about
Oh you sewed him back up good good good
why did I do that what was the point of
that nurse you're a very good nurse in
whatever or something I don't know
I got crayons oh I didn't need all the
crap oh I could have just gotten the
crayons any of that well that's the end
oh it just said I didn't even read that
it said next time just do the crayons
only for a different ending okay I'll do
that real quick BRB
okay I got it there was a different
route to go that I didn't need to make
the big guy go to the bathroom and I
didn't need to stab the guy in the leg
not that I did that before anyway but oh
damn it
damn it didn't mean to do that sorry
sorry okay I got the crayons
okay the nurse is happy with me I did
good well that wasn't a good ending oh
okay the drawings okay well that was the
alternate ending everybody I died but I
guess that means that I get reborn right
in the other world
great sorry bad dream hospice games are
so trippy and interesting it's like
really really fun to play I like them a
lot
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching there are three other
games in this series left to play I'm
probably still gonna keep playing them
because there are a lot of fun and I
hope you guys are enjoying them check
out the other scary games that I played
I played a lot of scary games in the
past and if you have any other horror
games that you have recommending to me
let me know in the comments below thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always
[Music]
[Applause]